c'est une époque qui semble bien
lointaine avec des annulations au mieux
des reports le monde de la culture est
dans l'incertitude et la reprise restent
timides alors pour relancer des actions
aider les acteurs culturels un million
d'euros a été débloquée par la région
centre val de loire
l'objectif c'est vraiment de maintenir
de l'emploi culturel et d'apporter une
aide aux créateurs aux artistes dans
notre région et à l'ensemble des lieux
de diffusion ce sera une prorogation par
rapport au budget de la structure c'est
pas si y'a pas un système de forfait ou
de cagnotte qui sera apportée on est
vraiment dans une étude au plus juste de
chacun chaque dossier dans ce théâtre de
200 places à lignières le directeur
chiffre à 90000 euros le manque à gagner
entre le mois de mars et de juin au delà
de la location potentiel qu'il peut
recevoir
ils jugent positif le soutien apporté
pendant pratiquement six mois on n'a pas
vu un seul spectateur simplement avoir
du soutien certes financier mais c'est
aussi un soutien humain c'est des gens
qui comprennent la situation qui essaie
de la comprendre et qui sont à nos côtés
qui comprend comprennent aussi qu'il
faut réduire les incertitudes et d
angoisses
ça c'est important aussi dans la région
près de 30 festival ont été annulés et
les lieux de spectacle ou de cinéma sont
loin de faire le plein de visiteurs
alors pour ce professionnel du secteur
il faut penser à moyen terme
je pense qu'il faut sauver tout de suite
une activité effectivement et sauver
aussi des gens des artistes qui sont
vraiment dans une grande difficulté
mais au-delà de ça il faudrait très très
attentif pour voir comment on va les
remettre en selle dans les années qui
viennent sinon j'allais dire on va les
sauver tout de suite
et puis reculer pour mieux sauter et les
problèmes vont apparaît dans un angle
dans deux ans quant aux subventions
annuelles de la région au monde de la
culture et des arts elles ont été
conservée intégralement